عندما يعرفك العالم باسم واحد فقط ،
لقد نجحت حقًا في أن يكون بيليه
أعظم
لاعب كرة قدم في كل العصور ، فإن سلوكه المتواضع
وروحه الكريمة
ضمنت إرثه كرمز عالمي ،
فهذه مسؤولية كبيرة كما تعلم أنني
أشعر براحة كبيرة  لأن
شيئًا لا يمكنني الإجابة عليه
هو لماذا أعطاني الله هذه ، فأنت تعلم أن
هذه الهدية كانت هدية من الله
وحاولت أن أكون في أفضل حالاتي ، وحاولت أن
أحترم الناس
أحاول أن أجهز نفسي وأحاول أن أكون
دائمًا في حالة جيدة كما تعلم  الأشخاص الأكثر
أهمية والأشخاص الذين نشأوا
في الأحياء الفقيرة في ساو باولو في الأربعينيات من القرن الماضي ،
اكتشف إدسون أرانتيس دي نايمنتو
كرة القدم في سن مبكرة ، حيث ظهر
لأول مرة مع سانتوس في سن 16 عامًا فقط
وفي غضون عام واحد سجل أهدافًا
للاعب البرازيلي.  بحلول هذا
الوقت ، اشتهر بلقبه
بيليه وفي عام 1958 عندما كان في السابعة عشرة من عمره أصبح
أصغر لاعب يلعب في نهائي كأس العالم
حيث سجل هدفين حيث فازت البرازيل على
السويد ، وكان هذا هو الأول من بين ثلاثة ألقاب عالمية.
لقد ساعد في الفوز لبلده ، لقد
أثار اهتمام الجماهير
بحركاته الرائعة وقدرته على تسجيل
أهداف تبدو ومحتملة ، لذا كان
من المخيب للآمال أن هدفه رقم 1000
كان بمثابة ركلة جزاء بالنسبة لي وهو رجل كوميدي
في البرازيل
قال.  استمع
الله أوقف اللعبة لأن كل شخص يجب
أن يرى الذهب 1000 الخاص بك وهذا السبب
كان ركلة الجزاء بعد هدفه
، توقفت المباراة ضد فاسكو دي جاما
لعدة دقائق للاحتفال
بإنجازه التاريخي في عام 1967
علم بيليه أنه وفريقه حصلوا على
القوة لوقف أشياء أخرى أيضًا عندما
دفعت زيارتهم لنيجيريا
الفصائل المتحاربة إلى الدعوة لوقف إطلاق النار لمدة 48 ساعة في
الحرب الأهلية في البلاد مع الفقراء
لأن الناس مجنونون
بكرة القدم لدرجة أنهم يحبون كرة القدم لدرجة أنهم
أوقفوا الحرب لرؤية سانتا يلعب في إفريقيا
هذه أغنية رائعة
لا يمكنك تفسيرها بحلول الوقت الذي تقاعد فيه بيليه
كلاعب كرة قدم في عام 1977 وهو يلعب
سنواته الأخيرة من أجل الكون في نيويورك ،
فقد أزال حياته المهنية.  من بين
1281 هدفًا ، كان بيليه قبل نصف
عمر ، لكن حبه المعدي
للعبة أكد أنه لا يزال
ذا صلة ، فقد عمل كسفير
للأمم المتحدة للبيئة والبيئة ، كان
يفرك أكتافه مع قادة الدول في جميع
أنحاء العالم وحصل على
وسام فخري  فارس من الملكة إليزابيث
في عام 1997.
الذي يمكن أن ينسى ظهوره في
فيلم عبادة Escape to Victory
هنا أنا أفعل هذه الأيام ، أصبح
[موسيقى]
سهلًا عندما لعب دور البطولة جنبًا إلى جنب مع مايكل
كين وسيلفستر ستالون وهو يلعب دور
أسير حرب سجل هدفًا مذهلاً
لتعزيز الروح المعنوية  في مباراة
ضد الألمان
، أعتقد أولاً وقبل كل شيء أنها هدية من
الله
ثانياً أعتقد أنه كان هناك الكثير من العمل الجاد
والتدريب ويجب
أنأقول
الحمد لله لأن والدي كان
لاعب كرة قدم وكان مركزًا له
ثم كان والدي
منشد الكمال الذي تعرفه ، ثم كل ما
كنت أفعله حاولت أن أفعله اعتاد
أن يقول
اسمعك تعلم أنك يجب أن تكون أفضل من أنه
كان دائمًا عالميًا.  يخدع ، لكن في
موطنه البرازيل ، سيتم
اعتباره دائمًا كنزًا وطنيًا لأنه
توفي سبب الحداد الوطني
، وكما قال ذلك بنفسه بروح الدعابة ،
لن يكون هناك بيليه آخر
صعبًا للغاية
لأن أمي وأبي
يغلقان الآلة